[Music]
fell pretty good welcome home great to
be home but I couldn't help but be
really pleased to see the Dean wearing a
business suit and Nike shoes you know
but I think we can all be and we can all
be glad that basically I was not the
founder of jockey underwear well we'll
try and make that a permanent change in
the Elevens wardrobe now I felt we know
you don't do too many public speaking
events and a question a lot of people
have asked is what does it take to get
Phil Knight up on stage so I thought
maybe we should share the story of what
got you here today
now you probably remember that we first
crossed paths a couple of months ago
just over there
make a McDonald Hall you were entering
the building when I very politely
interrupted you introduce myself we
exchanged a couple of pleasantries and
then you went on inside about your day
now what you're probably less aware of
Phil is that I decided to camp outside
McDonald Hall for the next 40 minutes
watching every possible human exit to
the building so that I could find you
and you know casually bump into you a
second time to pitch you this interview
it's creepy I know yeah that that's how
it happened I'll be honest I was pretty
nervous when you did come at that second
time it was fight or flight I very
nearly walked the other way but there
was this voice in my head it just kept
saying we'll just do it
but really Phil we are so thrilled and
excited to have you back on campus and I
think I speak for every student here
when I say how grateful we are for this
incredible business school well thank
you but you know having stalked me for
at least 40 minutes I feel that there
should be some payback oh I know that
most of you know that Will's mother mags
has come all the way from Ireland to be
here today and having come such a long
way I think you should reveal something
about yourself that she doesn't know so
I don't know what you're trying to
suggest I was a perfect child well did
you make your bed this morning I didn't
even sleep in my own bed this morning
cuz I gave it to my mom that wasn't what
it sounded like
all right now Phil Phil we don't want to
make you feel old huh this is payback by
the way yeah this could go back and
forth a long time that's right
but it's been almost 60 years yep since
you were here in our shoes an incoming
MBA class of 1962 what kind of person
was Phil Knight back at the GSB how
would you have described yourself yeah I
will but I wanted to tell you first
about coming back to campus after being
gone for a while
that you go out 20 years or so and you
haven't been back for a while and you
come back and it's more about just
sharing a moment with family and friends
it's for a moment you step back in
history and remember when you had all
the worldwide laying out before you and
you decided the things that you were
going to find important and it was
really the start of you becoming what he
ultimately became when I come back for
just a moment I always hear the voice of
Frank Shallenberger Bob Davis Jim
porterfield
and I know that sounds sort of corny to
educated group but I promise you that
over half
the people in this room when they come
back here 20 years from now will have
those same feelings you know for me you
know it was well yeah that I was the guy
that thought an extrovert was the person
that stared at other people's shoes that
the the it was a time for me to kind of
grow and and chase what I was really
going to become and so it was really a
big transitional period for me in my
life and as I say to this day when I
come back I still get inspired and
lifted up do you've any favorite
memories from your days back at Stanford
oh that no it was just a turning point
in general for me that you know my if I
was honest I'd say that my undergraduate
career was really focused on track and
it got to be when I got to be a graduate
student that has really focused on what
it was I wanted to be and this was just
the right school at the right time with
the right inspirational professors and
it really doesn't get any better than
that
mm-hmm so you do graduate the GSB in
1962 yep it's the time when Silicon
Valley isn't even a phrase yet right and
you had what you call this crazy idea
what was the crazy idea and where did it
come about well I took the
entrepreneurship class from Frank
Shallenberger and basically the project
he had a term project where you
basically either attached yourself to a
company in the area or for the purpose
of the paper made up a company and and
how it would succeed and even in those
days a lot of my classmates were writing
about electronics which was certainly
beyond me since when I turn on a light
bulb when I turn on the electric switch
the light bulb comes on it's magic for
me but my old track coach was always
working with shoes and that felt that
you know a light lightweight and shoes
was something that was neglected by the
major manufacturers Adidas and Puma and
indeed my senior year Otis Davis won the
Pacific Coast Conference championship
and a pair of homemade Bowerman shoes
which were ounce elated lighter than the
other shoes so I kind of put those
things together
and and said if you were starting a shoe
factory would you still
in Germany and I said it's such a
labor-intensive business it makes more
sense to start it in Japan Japan being
the country that took German cameras
didn't and dominated the camera market
says could they do the same thing in
sports use now it's really the thesis of
the paper which ultimately I got caught
up in and here we are now you got an A
in that paper right I did okay but that
mattered if he ridiculed the paper I
don't know where we do today well this
was a time when entrepreneurship post
GSB was not just a last travel path it
was probably a less celebrated path what
gave you the confidence to push ahead
well if I didn't know I was gonna have
to be an accountant and now that's
that's a scary thought no it was no but
it was a it was when I wrote the paper
it it just stayed in my head and at the
time I think the the ratio was the 26
out of 12 27 new companies failed so I
knew the odds weren't high but I really
began to feel if I could do this that
would really be meaningful to me and
something that I would really have a lot
of passion for and about and so that's
where it started and away we went
now two years in many of your classmates
have gone dan more traditional career
paths you're back in Oregon you're
living in your old room in the family
house and you're selling shoes out of
the trunk of your car did you ever have
dates in those moments and what was it
that kept you going well obviously there
were a lot of doubts but that I enjoyed
what I was doing and I really thought
that I was bringing a product to the
world that was better than the other
product and and so I believed and and if
you read the book wasn't too long before
I had a bunch of other people that
believed as well and we just through all
the ups and downs and there were plenty
of downs that we never stopped believing
and
so a lot of people say why did you stay
with it there were a lot of negative
moments and a lot of downturns and and I
look back on those days the most fun I
ever had in business it was it was that
every day every Monday you went to work
and you knew it mattered what you did
including whether you're gonna meet
payroll on Friday but it was an exciting
time and that that Frank Shallenberger
had done a wonderful job of preparing us
for you know being an entrepreneur Bob
Davis a marketing professor said if
you're gonna be an entrepreneur he said
every day is a crisis in every Fridays
at Jesus crisis it was kind of the way
it was
now you also talk in your book Sherdog
about those early trips to Asia mm-hmm
so you're 24 years old traveling alone
to Japan it's a culture you don't know a
language you don't speak to try and
broker that first shoe import deal so
this was a time before Stanford's global
study trip Sergey mixes where did that
ability to embrace hustle and
uncertainty come from in you well by the
time I got there I believed and so that
I believed that it was a good idea I
believe that if we can I get a
cooperative Japanese factory that I
could make the idea of work and so yeah
that overcame you know when you're
bidding I'm an entrepreneur
and introvert why you basically have to
you have to believe you have to overcome
the shyness to to take certain chances
and I was willing to do that and you
know there were a lot of ups and downs
but ultimate worked and you know I think
at the end of the day you got to believe
and and that's what I did have maybe
above everything else mm-hmm no as you
said the team grew and you weren't alone
in this endeavor and I think there's no
story of Nike with that of course
mentioning Bill Bowerman your former
track coach at Oregon later US Olympics
track coach and of course your
co-founder what became Nike you've
described yourself as a person who's
always needed heroes
why was bill a hero to you and what is
it you learn from him well he was a very
unique person that that he was probably
the best track and field coach in world
for one thing but he was also at a
certain command presence and a certain
belief in certain leadership things that
the leaders did you know he he said I'm
not a I'm not a track coach he says I'm
a professor of competitive response and
he he had a way of having sayings that
got your attention and really focused
you on attitude his strategy for running
the mile was start out and run the first
two laps at a very fast pace run the
third lap as fast as you can
on the fourth lap triple your speed and
and they said that you know the Oregon
Trail he says the the Cour the the
cowards never started in the week died
along the way that leaves you and me and
that's once again him getting it kind of
kind of your attitude and is his best
one for me it was always do right and
fear no man and so he had a big
influence on my life certainly the
biggest influence other than my parents
and if you go back through this sayings
and who he was he was always working on
attitude this is a man that had seen
combat in World War two
you know fired a gun and been fired at
and he had seen competition that it's
its most extreme level and he thought he
could his job as a confessor professor
of competitive response was to get kids
ready for young men and young women
ultimately to be ready for the the
toughest competition they can face so
you know he brought to me you know a
certain attitude which you can be an
introvert and have attitude and so that
was sort of me and he had a huge
influence on that and and he was a hero
of mine in those days and to this day
mm-hmm when you first met him you
described it as love and fear at first
sight right and then there was a little
hate that came after that he really kind
of believed in hazy
that and you had to prove that you
wanted to be there and so he would make
you go through hoops which I did
somewhat reluctantly now beyond bill of
course you talk with a lot of affection
about that core early Nike team and I
think you had a name for each other
right well yeah we did oh I see you're
playing that game now that the first
four or five people in the company we
wound up calling each other but faces
which we don't do that anymore were more
professional group now you know our view
from the top team we've a similar name
for each other actually it's good it's
healthy but what was it about that early
team and that culture that made it so
successful well I think first of all
they were a bizarre group to say the
least each of them in his own way but
they were and I hope this showed in a
book that they were able very able
people that really kind of didn't get
along with society in general so it was
kind of a perfect fit and they
complemented each other in terms of
their abilities and then lastly all of
them believed it was they they just when
we would hit a down period nobody
thought this is in okay okay we got to
get together and find their way out of
this one and so it was fun being a
foxhole with those guys and and
basically it's corny but we loved each
other and we were going to go through
this come hell or high water and it was
a very exciting intense time and it as I
say I love those times mm-hmm you fought
a lot of crises together
yeah for sure in recent years Phil we've
seen many high-profile disruptive
companies being pressured to rein in
what we're seeing is aggressive macho
win at all costs cultures cultures that
have brought these companies so much
early success in their life just last
year Nike faced some similar accusations
and the management team made some pretty
decisive changes when you grow from a
start-up to a 74,000 person team
how do you preserve the best of that
winning culture in a more complex
diverse global workforce yeah well he
touched on a lot of things there that I
mean I do think that Becky's culture is
a big part of its reasons for success
and the culture really was formed in the
early days by the way the four people
plus me and it still exists to this day
I'd say a lot of people say well if Phil
had a dominant influence on that and he
didn't
I mean I've often said many times Nike
is young and irreverent and I'm neither
that but it did it did to use barman's
word addict they came within a certain
attitude and and it was sort of us
that's who we were and the culture has
been modified some and which is a good
thing and but it's still kind of
basically there and I think it's a big
part of its strength that yeah so I I
hope that that culture is is basically
in place you know twenty years from now
it and and it's one thing it fits with
sort of our view then and now about what
a brand is you know it doesn't matter
how many people hate your brand as long
as enough people love it and as long as
you have that out you can't be afraid of
offending people you can't try and go
down in the middle of the road you have
to take a stand on something which is
ultimately I think why the Kapernick had
worked mm-hmm well that's let's jump
into those athletes so I want to take
you back to 1978 Phil you stumble across
a shy timid retiring Stanford tennis
player by the name of John McEnroe timid
I wouldn't say
[Laughter]
well we got to see a little bit of John
in that video but for anyone who doesn't
know tennis John is a young fantastic
tennis player who's as well known for
breaking racquets as he is breaking
serve he is everything that the tennis
establishment at the time the major
majority of the market was not so what
made him the right ambassador for Nike
well the the the story basically we had
an agreement with Jimmy Mac Jimmy
Connors agent for him to were in high
case shoes and he did he warm that will
Melton and the agent said as soon as he
gets back from Wilmington we'll get it
signed well they won one Milton and soon
he got back from Europe boy he had
summer matches and then came the US Open
and he said as soon as we get done with
the US Open we'll get this contract
signed well they won the US Open and
then we got down to sign the contract
says I don't remember it this way that
was Jimmy Connors agent not Jimmy
Connors
but that was the end of our endorsement
with Jimmy Connors and so the next year
I think it was that well I went to
Wilmington you know looking for the next
great hope and there were a bunch of
really good American young Americans 18
and under I was looking at the 18 and
unders and they had Brian Godfrey who is
a great player in Elliot Telstra was a
great player and the head of USA tennis
was saying those are really great
endorsements stay away from that kid
McEnroe he's too much of a hothead he's
playing over on court 14 I went right to
Fort 14 and basically that week he was
playing the number 16 player in the
world filled int and he's 18 years old
and hits his first serve in and the
chalk flies up and the line judge goes
out McEnroe jumps over the net puts his
nose this far from the official he says
are you sure that call are you very sure
that call Wow and I turned to the guys
with his this kids not afraid and you
know I kind of became a fan of his
intensity and his competitiveness and
his attitude he did lose control
sometimes but that well I always
remember Frank Deford right
of Hindman and Sports Illustrated when
he said a big picture of mechanist why
isn't this man smiling
Beethoven didn't smile much either
that's fair
a few years later actually several years
later you decided to name the executive
building at your headquarters in Oregon
after John McEnroe what is it you were
trying to say to the team at Nike in
doing that well we named all the
buildings after our heroes at the time
and you know he was one of them and that
just that was where my office was fair
enough you're glad to see him back
playing well and I that makes me feeling
better now let's fast-forward to 1984
you come across another decent
basketball players name is Michael
Michael Jordan Jordan Michael Jordan
that's it now Nike were actually
criticized at the time for overpaying
for Jordan's signature but of course
with hindsight he became more than an
athlete he became a two and a half
billion dollar revenue brand for Nike
beyond MJ's greatness what was it that
made that brand so successful and so
dominant yeah it's it isn't something
you can bottle it's been you know truly
one of the unique experiences really in
all of marketing that obviously he had
it all and and we pretty much knew that
coming in I mean he was Player of the
Year he was handsome he could jumping
and that he won the national
championship with a winning shot yeah at
all but and yeah when we signed him we
signed him for more than any rookie had
been paid before was signing for
$250,000 a year and fortune magazine ran
a little insert another article says
there's no greater indication that Nike
has lost its way than the fact that they
paid Michael Jordan $250,000 and but
that it's but we can't combined it with
what we thought was a really good shoe a
really distinctive shoe was red and
black it wasn't just white or black and
of course he wore to great and great
performances and then we had the added
benefit of David Stern banned it in the
NBA so he immediately
mind what became a good ad says banned
in the NBA and every kid in the world
one of that and that and it's it hasn't
been straight uphill it had a one year
where sales actually went down but
overall that was the what we got
together was really good advertising
which reflected his personality which
was strong and it's been an unbelievable
success that when he quit playing sales
of Jordan Brand product over 750 million
dollars and this last fiscal year they
topped three billion dollars and long
after he quit planned so as I said to
many people imagine how much we'd sell
if he'd never played we can only dream
Phil its Nikes 55th anniversary next
week I believe yeah the company's at
record revenue levels and just last year
Nike was voted alongside Apple as the
favored brand of Millennials and I think
there's a few of us in here who might
attest to that how does a brand stay so
relevant to so many people for so long
well it's it's hard work but you have to
work at it all the time but I think you
know our thing obviously it starts with
the product the the product is by far
most marketing our most important
marketing tool and so we're constantly
working to improve product and so the
kind of the recent upturn is because
we've had a really good product pipeline
probably the react running shoe is
number one on the list but there's been
a lot of others and that so that's
that's been really important and then
you know good advertising is critical to
it that you know that the Wieden and
Kennedy experience has been is in many
ways as dramatic as Nikes and it's
really been kind of a long slide each
other when I first met Dan Wyden I
walked into the door of his quote office
he had three people besides himself
sitting around a card table and he said
welcome to widen Kennedy and I just want
you to know one thing I hate advertising
and he looked at me says well this would
be interesting
and it has been but it is interesting
that you know obviously if I would have
said that Procter & Gamble I'd have been
on they take your 25 million take your
$25 advertising budget and go on at the
door but they were a small advertising
firm and he grew to understand that what
I didn't mean was that I hated
advertising what I meant was I hate
traditional advertising and he found
ways to find out who Nike is or who
Michael Jordan was and project that to
the consumer and not only the Nike you
know succeed Wieden and Kennedy now has
offices all over the world you know over
a thousand employees it has coca-cola as
a client as Honda's a client has a lot
of the world's most famous brands its
clients they've been an enormous success
and to this day they work really hard at
trying to find out you know who it is
and who the athlete is and how to
project them I know we had Boris Becker
the great tennis players and we were
trying to get him as an endorsement and
Dan Wyden was making the pitch and he
says we will find out who you are and
project that to the world and Morris
says how in the world can you know who I
am when I don't know who I am
and just said well we'll find out
well we didn't we didn't make the sale
he didn't we didn't get this we didn't
sell him but but that is one of the
things they've done so the advertising
and the product are two of the two the
really important things and then keeping
the product for us and keeping the
advertising fresh and it's an ongoing
challenge and we don't always hit it you
know a couple years ago we took a little
dip and it's a very very competitive
business and in every six months is kind
of a new life and everybody has to be
aware that mmm Phil this is a school and
a speaker series dedicated to leadership
so we want to make sure we we touch on
that topic something the MBA one class
is challenged with each year is why
would someone follow you I think there
can be a stereotype of what a CEO should
be sometimes we think of them as a
natural extrovert around the valley
sometimes they can be hero like
characters you described yourself as shy
introverted someone who identifies with
the Bourne
however those that's why that's why we
get on that but but how if those traits
helped you as you built Nike well I
think you know I mean obviously
introverted introverted people have a
tendency to listen which I think good
leaders do but when I was in school that
you know they talked about two different
types of leadership they talked about
autocratic leadership and Democratic
leadership and you know it was only 15
years after World War two and you know
they had two of the great autocratic
leaders everyone Douglas MacArthur and
George Patton and they at the time
looked on as being very successful that
then you have a democratic style
leadership which is you know the thing
is getting people involved and talking
to people and that so I think for it's
probably almost impossible for an intro
to be an autocratic leader but Internet
can be a Democratic leader and the idea
of democratic leadership progressed this
is the this started to talk use the term
collaborative leadership which is really
in my view the ultimate and only kind of
leadership to this day that in this day
and age autocratic leader doesn't work
it can work for temporarily but it won't
work long run and I hope that the people
in this in this auditorium today don't
get the idea that hero leadership means
being autocratic and you know that I
mean obviously I think Steve Jobs has
looked at is really kind of in this area
of one whole world really has been one
of the great leaders which I believe he
was but I do believe at the end of his
career he was beginning to modify his
you know natural autocratic style which
if you will got him fired his first tour
around Apple and as he got to go through
Apple the second time there was a change
in Steve Jobs and you notice that from
the commencement speech he gave to to
Stanford University and and he hired Tim
Cook and he had a lot of give-and-take
with Tim Cook and Tim Cook who I know
quite well is very much a collaborative
leader and and I believe a great
collaborative leader so I think that you
it just
don't equate hero leadership with
autocratic leadership the only Thai
style of leadership that will work in
this day and age is collaborative
leadership mm-hmm I fell another thing
you may know about this group is that
we're pretty touchy-feely bunch these
days of course in your book you describe
business as war without bullets yeah so
as you look back in those early days and
I keep dealing with those crises
we're solve skills tools an entrepreneur
like you could really afford back then
what type of what type of skills are
talking about the softer skills the
touchy-feely well I think yeah I mean
yeah I think that looks you dog
obviously I don't come across as a
touchy-feely type and neither were any
of those top five but there's lots of
different ways of communicating and I
one of the things I don't like about the
politically correct movement is that to
me it politically correct has been
founded by people that couldn't
communicate and they don't want you to
communicate very well either
because communications really is a kind
of an individual thing everybody's a
little bit different it's like people
have different fingerprints they have
different personalities they have
different emotions and I think the
leaders job is to know who his team is
and there's different ways to
communicate with that team
we weren't touchy-feely in the sense
that we were always patting each other
back and say how we feel but you could
say how you doing today son of a [ __ ]
didn't mean the same thing and so
there's just different ways the
different ways to to do they like to do
that mm-hmm I think we need to bring
that into the chatter on campus these
days
now Phil we we also study a lot here had
leaders act in times of crisis Nike and
yourself have dealt with several today
the Nike brand is stronger than ever but
of course in the late 90s Nike did for
some time become synonymous with
sweatshops and slave wages as you look
back how do you feel you handle that
crisis what would you do differently and
what are you most proud of
well the one of the things that that we
didn't talk about in Business School
when I was here was the media and so I
think probably this group is probably
much more aware of the media but it's
it's always there it's more prevalent
than it's ever been and they're not
always consumed by facts that and so
when they when they first charges came
at Nike run sweatshops that you know
it's a it's a really seductive argument
to say this person only makes four
dollars a day and Michael Jordan makes
you know thirty million dollars a year
and Phil Knights worth two billion
dollars and and isn't this awful and but
our initial reaction was that we don't
run sweatshops and that you're wrong and
I was the CEO at the time and that was
my strategy and it was awful it didn't
work and so we kind of after about a
year that it became clear and so we took
another tack which says yeah you can you
can criticize the ones but this is what
we're going to be and this is how we're
going to be a better company over the
next ten years and we're going to take
these steps each year and you come look
at any of our factories anywhere in the
world that you want and we've kind of
been on that path ever since and that's
basically working and I do think you
know that we have had lots of good
comments that don't get much publicity
from the media and you know one of the
good ones was a member
the United Nations says Nikes the gold
standard for all apparel companies and
how they run their run their factories
and it's a constant battle oh because
we're always kind of looking for new
factories or changing factories and we
have most of our shoe factories and our
good apparel collectors have been with
us for 20 or 25 years but economics
change at different times so you do
change some of them on the periphery so
it's a constant battle to live up to the
standards we have but we have a whole
team at Nike that does that all the time
and basically is talking to people on
the production line all the time and I
do think that our factories are the best
in the world right now for conditions
and and it's it's a basic truth that
great shoes are made by great factories
you don't want a you know you know a bad
factory making your ear the best shoes
in the world that feels something else
we hear a lot from the media but also
occasionally at Stanford is to find and
follow your passion and you are perhaps
the example of someone who built a
business dedicated to something they
love which is sports and athletes
there's many of us in the room today who
I feel are struggling to maybe tie our
true passions to a viable business or
career what would you say to people like
us well I think you know that one thing
that is left out is that you got to have
a niche you got to have a reason to
succeed my reason that was that you know
Japan could make shoes economically and
that but then the rest of it you know
fit right and home base for me so and I
do think if you're gonna be an
entrepreneur it has to be something that
you really love because there will be a
lot of dark days and as I say we never
hesitated in those mark dark days so I I
was fortunate enough to find what I
thought was a niche to go with my
passion and that's that's what you need
to bring those two things together but
when you do you're very very fortunate
and take advantage of it mm-hmm all
right well look Phil this has been
brilliant thus far I know Nike say there
is no finish line we do need to finish
in about 15 minutes Phil this has been
brilliant we're almost gonna let you go
not quite yet there's a little tradition
we like to do up here on stage and
called a lightning round so the idea is
I'm gonna ask you a set of either/or
questions we want you to answer the one
answer that comes first in your mind
okay you didn't warn me about this you
didn't tell me you were gonna mention me
I might get back to her all right look
because it's a new thing we're gonna
start easy and then we'll get harder
okay so Jordan or LeBron that's like
asking which of your kids do you like
better okay you can tell me backstage is
fine
Rose Bowl or Super Bowl Rose Bowl 340
mile or two hour marathon
two hour marathon nice suit or track
suit oh man track suit just do it or
dream crazy just do it
Hawaii or Palm Springs Hawaii Beatles
the Rolling Stones Beatles that was easy
Breaking Bad or The Sopranos who
probably Sopranos but that's tough we
were told it was tough for you
adidas or barefoot barefoot
ladies and gentlemen Phil Knight
fine
[Music]
you